(audience cheering)
- I know! Legend!
- Welcome to New York.
- [Kelly] Thank you! I love it.
- I'm so glad you're here.
- [Kelly] I, man, I love it so much.
- [Martha] Are you
living on the west side?
- I know, it's just
everything, the energy,
everything is very much me.
I'm very (sings in high tone)
- I do a lot.
- You know
- You do a lot.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- So that's New York too.
- [Kelly] I know, but
that's why I fit in. Yeah.
Anything special for Thanksgiving?
- Oh, I gave up Thanksgiving.
I canceled...
Somebody canceled...
Nine guests canceled
because somebody got sick.
- Oh, no.
- So I decided,
I called up my chef friend
and I said, "We're not
doing Thanksgiving."
- Yeah.
- And I've also cooked
like 14 turkeys already for my TV show.
- [Kelly] You've kind of done it. Yeah.
- [Martha] And I, and I still
have to do one more Turkey,
I think on the Today Show so...
- We're Little turkeyed out.
- I am turkeyed out.
- I hope you have Taco
Thursday or something on.
(Martha laughing)
Yeah, yeah. And just
have like, have tacos.
- So I'm going...
No, I made a plan.
Friends, of course,
invited me to their home,
so I'm going to about five different homes
to taste different courses.
You know, do a...
- [Kelly] Oh my God, those
friends must be so stressed out.
- [Martha] Oh, I hope so. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah. I was like,
if you were coming to my
house, I would for sure lie
and say I cooked and
have somebody else do it.
Like, I was like (Kelly laughing)